quentin tarantino is being sued by the
production company miramax over his pulp
fiction nft plans
yes basically so you understand quentin
tarantino decided
to
make some nfts he's been getting pitched
on this for uh uh some amount of time i
saw online in an interview somebody was
explaining nfts to him and he kind of
thought it was interesting so he took
seven pages of the pulp fiction script
and was going to make an nft out of
seven pages that were left out scenes
that are not in the movie what a clever
great idea now the only problem is
miramax owns pub fiction and the way
these contracts tend to work uh having
seen them up close when i worked at sony
music
or other
media companies
you buy a piece of ip intellectual
property like a movie or a song or an
album or a piece of art or a comic book
character or a comic book or a book and
in that contract it says we have the
right to develop this in the future in
perpetuity in all mediums known and
unknown
in the future in other words if new
mediums come out we get to exploit this
ip and that's included in the price we
paid you for it so i'm assuming i don't
know this that his contract when they
bought pulp fiction they bought all
rights to it including sequels and this
other stuff which is why sometimes
you'll see a director say i have nothing
to do with the exorcist sequel i have
nothing to do with the jaws
sequels beyond number two whatever spiel
i don't even know spielberg probably
wasn't involved in even number two so
the sequel rights is obviously a big
thing and then there's what's called
derivative rights uh you know things
made like merchandise and they're
outlined in contracts and you can
negotiate that i get to keep the
merchandise in fact george lucas did
that famously with star wars that's why
he became so rich was because he used
his money uh to um
pay for the creation of the star wars
movies but kept the merchandise rights
et cetera et cetera he wound up
obviously selling all of that uh ip2
disney and now disney if they want to
sell nfts i don't think lucas gets to
sell his nfts however this is untested
law because
there are a couple of issues here well
these are things quentin tarantino wrote
but did not sell
right these were not sold
as part of pulp fiction they didn't buy
the original script if they did buy the
original ship they certainly didn't buy
the notes or pages around it
but they do own the title pulp fiction
so
then you would make the argument
well you're trafficking in rip and using
our ip to sell these things that are
adjacent to it now if you just took the
seven pages from the script and he sold
them at an auction
i don't think that
uh miramax would care but i think
miramax is owned by disney i believe
somebody can fact check me on that
therefore
disney probably wants to put their foot
down on this and say wait we got to stop
this before
you know stan lee's estate or you know
somebody who drew iron man starts going
in their draws and says listen i got a
hundred copies of sketches i did of iron
man i'm gonna start selling them
okay so the walt disney company owned
uh miramax from 93 to 2010 uh got sold
to a couple different holding companies
and now it's owned by viacom cbs
according to disney.fandom.com
now if you owned a copy of
a comic book if i owned a comic book and
i cut each of the pages and i made
you know 60 pages of this graphic novel
and i framed them and i sold them page
by page am i allowed to do that yes i am
i bought that comic book i chopped it up
but now if i make another work out of
like a digital work am i allowed to make
a new story of it am i allowed to cut
them up and make a montage and then play
that into a film of course not right so
these laws uh when they hit new
technologies always get tested it's not
really a big deal this happened with
dvds and cds and
streaming famously and generally there's
a negotiation if people feel like
they're getting the raw end of the stick
because you want somebody
to maybe participate so the right way to
do this and what you'll eventually see
here is the director quentin tarantino
will then go on to miramax
and they would cut a deal where
quentin would say listen i have this
archive of all of this interesting stuff
i want an nft do you have an nf
preferred nft platform like yeah we do
it with this company or we started our
own nft platform great so quentin
tarantino's collection ridley scott's
collection of blade runner and gladiator
stuff in
partnership with disney would then sell
them right so that that's how this stuff
tends to work out and so
according to the wall street journal
bart williams who's a partner at the law
firm of prosper rose i think is how you
pronounce it on behalf of merrimack
stated quote
it was profoundly disappointing to learn
of this deliberate
premeditated short-term money grab by
the tarantino team to unilaterally
circumvent miramax's rights to pulp
fiction through the illicit development
promotion distribution of nfts so that's
a pretty over the top statement i don't
know why they would be
so aggressive about this they i'm
assuming went to quentin tarantino and
said like
hey
let's uh
let's work something out first but
tarantino probably told him to pounce
all because maybe he uh
doesn't agree with them or maybe he's
got some past friction with them and
this is part of an overall negotiation
remember we saw something similar uh
with none other than dave chappelle and
the chappelle show and he was like hey
don't watch the chappelle show they're
screwing me out of money and then i
guess comedy central and chappelle
figured out a way to bury their beef
which is good because then chappelle
gets to
work on this ip and support in the
future in fact when howard stern left
terrestrial radio part of him leaving
and i think staying for an extra year or
something was when he negotiated his
further contracts he said i want to own
my tapes i want all of my tapes for
history to be owned by me my master's
basically not these other westwood one
or whoever you worked for previously i'm
not sure
and he actually owns his archive now and
i think with his uh deal with sirius he
owns a company that then gives them the
show but he still retains his ip and all
that so as you move up the stack you can
then reacquire your ip and use your
current partnership as bait for that so
what tarantino should do here is
you should go to miramax and say listen
i want to have some ownership in my
archive or something like that is there
some deal we could cut here
but you know there's really no reason
for the movie studios to do that so you
know he's only going to do one more of
these
um
you know
i don't see it as a money grab i see it
as an experiment and maybe they should
collaborate on it
if you're trying to nail an important
project before the end of the year you
might need some extra help i know i do
well look no further than fiverr
business fiber business puts a world of
expert freelancers at your fingertips so
you can get any project across the
finish line and be really proud of your
work it is really hard to hire full-time
people right now plus fiverr has
everything you need to seamlessly
integrate your new team members into
your workflow we love fiverr here at
lunch we hired a bunch of researchers
researchers right so we were able to
scale up very quickly they went out and
they got us leads and i didn't have to
take my key employees off of investing
in companies or producing the podcast
they just took the research and they
started on second or third base average
just works so stop wasting time
searching for talent that may never
arrive just leave it to five for
business they have a team of dedicated
business success managers that will help
match you with the best talent for your
team but man if you get that business
success manager they're gonna hand hold
you so no more endless guessing no more
interviews you can also save your
favorite freelancers for huge projects
which is kind of cool so find the
freelancers you need and give your next
project the boost that it needs to give
you a strong finish right now you can
sign up for fiverr business absolutely
free for the first year get one free
year and save ten percent on your
purchase of fiverr business with the
promo code jason that's right go to
fiverr.com business and don't forget the
promo code jasonjson
that's
dot fiverr.com slash business remember
there's two hours in fiverr
f-i-v-e-r-r dot com slash business use
the promo code jason